let me tell you the democrats have shown
us
that they do not believe in human rights
okay i'm not exaggerating i agree with
you
we're seeing it now in los angeles with
mayor garcetti straight up saying
we will take away your water if you
if you try to uphold your first
amendment right to peaceably assemble
this is insane dwp authorized to cut
utilities
at party homes mayor announces sure
the first amendment says peaceably
assemble it doesn't say for what reason
you have a right to have a gathering end
of story in the constitution
this they're not even talking about
locking up did you know that people who
go to jail get water
that's a good point you go to jail you
get water you go to jail there's
electric lights
yeah and and so and depending on where
you go
i mean you have tvs you can watch tv
you'll have electricity in prison
you'll actually have access to medical
care but if you defy
mayor garcetti he will take water away
from you
now i understand electricity too think
about this what happens if somebody's
having a party
and they have insulin in their
refrigerator and he cuts their power off
that's a good point they're going to die
people people need to understand this
especially about power outages
and cutting off utilities is that there
are some people who
literally need it in the immediate to
survive insulin needs to be refrigerated
oxygen
oxygen yep you cut off the power to
somebody because they're partying and
they got gramp upstairs and an oxygen
tank
he dead this is an insane threat to
violate human rights
and someone just said welcome to china
foreign
china foreign china thanks chad let me
show you this tweet
i said welcome to the world you created
it is everything you asked for and
everything we warned would happen
twitter is now
locking the accounts of people fact
checking trump
and of course you can see aaron rupar
he's been
blocked twitter shut him down because he
was trying to fact
fact check the president you've got this
guy bobby lewis and you've got this
woman liz power
these people are all complaining that
twitter has forced them to delete their
own tweets
because they were saying things that
twitter didn't like
huh yeah but on the other side on the
left
oh this happens to the left all the time
okay if there is any
any particular group of people that
lacks the ability to
learn it is leftists who continually ask
for censorship because
invariably they're the ones who get
censored i mean it's the same thing with
second amendment
how insane would you have to be right
now to be like we demand that the
government sees you know national gun
control
sees all the weapons and donald trump is
a fascist
what are you out of your mind i did i i
am starting to see more lefties say that
though and i'm like thank you
there was a funny post where it's
refreshing isn't it well somebody
somebody posted a meme on facebook i saw
and it said like
you know we need national gun control
the rest of the world looks
like like idiots it's time to confiscate
you know high-powered weapons and
weapons of war
and the first comment was from one sen
was from a guy who was like i'm really
far left but i've been thinking about
this and
i mean trump's a fascist i don't think
we should have him take our guns away
through hey they're starting to realize
it but the reason i bring this up is
what they're doing in l.a is
my mind was blown when i heard this
story it is above and beyond
violating human rights to take away
their clean water yeah it is like
because completely
there are even laws i'm curious if i
don't know if california has this law
but i know like i think arizona does
if you go to a store and you say can i
have water they have to give it to you
right
i mean so that's there's a lot of places
like that for a lot of reasons yeah no
in the south
arizona because it it gets so hot there
that
people could die from dehydration very
easily so if someone walks in and says
can i please have some water
it's it's illegal to say no no now many
people will say the mayor is just
threatening it
oh he's just through is it is that an
argument he's just threatening to take
away people's civil rights oh sure i'm
sorry human rights this is what my
friend i had a friend who was messaging
me the other night she's like cars are
driving around
they're checking people's houses i was
like are you serious they're checking
them
out yeah she's over in california wow
yeah
like the cops are going to people's
homes i had to double check but yeah she
said cars are driving and making sure
that people
why would anyone in their right mind
want to live
in california at this point new york and
california have become
it's it's it's it's despotism it's like
they're fighting to to be the
the best authoritarian state
who can who can be more authoritarian
this is a crazy story man he says
you're breaking the law you know you
know it scares me more than this
it's not a law no no but mandate no no
what scares me is this guy right here
behind him
who's this guy i have no idea he's
wearing a badge
yeah a badge but it doesn't look like he
is a an officer it's like he's a
private security guy with a badge on his
nose he's got the black bar which
represents a fallen officer
oh okay he looks like he's a cop okay
maybe he's not i don't know
but it's not even about that the mayor
said that he had authorized the
department of water and power to cut
utilities within four to eight hours
after parties were confirmed by the lapd
you're breaking the law that's so crazy
what law
first amendment says i can peaceably
assemble yeah period
period supreme court ruled that in
nevada churches couldn't be over a
certain capacity so they did that church
the
evangelicals held a church ceremony
invented at a casino
or or that video of today in a walmart
walmart they were singing in walmart
it was amazing that's awesome just just
hearing it honestly i'm not religious
but it lifted me up hearing the the the
joy and the the
reverence of what they were they were
doing i mean they were
they were basically saying to the man fu
we're going to join up together oh yeah
check this out it's from post-millennial
so it says
barred from attending church christians
held worship service at a walmart and
they were singing
and man was it was it good to hear how
long
will people sit back and accept
something like this
so i'll tell you what man stay out of
california i'm not even kidding
no joke and i know there's probably a
lot of you watching who live there
i think if it listen man first they came
for we understand where this goes
if the mayor of your town is threatening
to strip you of human rights and
no one opposes him how long i mean i'm
i'm
how long until they just walk up and
they just disappear you
good point if they have this this this
much disdain for human rights
they think they're entitled to do this
we've we've crossed the rubicon in this
man
there's no turning back the mayor has
straight up said this he should be
removed immediately
now impeached whatever they complain
about donald trump tweeting
i kid you not cnn they're like the
president is showing his fascistic
tendencies again by saying maybe we
should postpone an election due to
mail-in voter problems
it's like trump tweeted about postpone
the election
you say no end of story
yeah and congress says that's up to us
and maybe he can have some
national security you know directive but
but
no i'm sorry the trump tweeting stoo the
trump the president tweeting
things doesn't concern me at all the
donald trump when
the mayor of la holds a press conference
and says within 48 hours of you having a
legal assembly
you're breaking the law and we will take
away your water
[Music]
i understand thinking about taking away
your power too but imagine like
having like from say last year 2019
you're like i'm gonna plan my wedding
in this beautiful place in california
and you know somewhere
you know maybe maybe in my my friend's
house napa valley napa valley where
wine i'm gonna have all my friends and
family in august
august in l.a yeah nope mm-hmm
i'm gonna shut your power off and shut
off your power yep
you're breaking the law and in new
jersey they've been arresting people
having parties constitutionally
protected
you're allowed to assemble for any
reason well
literally not any reason but peaceable
assembly
i mean like i'm sure if you're
assembling to commit some kind of crime
that would not be you know
right they'd probably come in and be
like you're getting a friend so he said
he's telling people to break in their
law why because they're hanging out
together
above and beyond man so so i'm i'm
inspired by this story from
post-millennial
that people are resilient so they were
singing in a walmart
that was awesome that's crazy man it was
awesome you know what's really crazy is
uh uh
michael tracy journalist tweeted this
that he's at some small he's in some
small town or something
and the people there told them they
didn't wear masks until
walmart mandated masks wow because
walmart's like more influential
than the government so it's like wow
once they manage it people are like okay
fine i guess
the great thing is they were social
distancing
you can see that they were spread out in
the videos i mean you can't
really see it very well but i mean you
could see that they're spreading out
that's correct but they they went around
the store and just they were
singing it was awesome good one
thank you i said big dummy me i don't
know i ain't never
be allowed before wow man thank you very
[Applause]
much
yeah there's only so much you can
actually do to try and shut down
people's spirit
their faith that's why i'm curious like
at what point will someone
intervene because california you know so
this is just los angeles
and this is what scares me about any any
place that is dominated by one party
los angeles has been has had a
democratic super majority for
very very long time and they've not been
able to solve any of their problems
they've got a serious nimby mentality
for a lot of the people in in downtown
l.a
one of the worst homeless problems in
the country and all of these democrats
together could not solve it
whenever they try and talk about you
know building housing or affordable
housing
it just falls apart you look at chicago
you look at new york the exact same
thing you know the craziest thing is
with new york
now now i want to make sure i stress the
psychosis of the violation of human
rights
bill de blasio basically mocked rich
people
really yeah so so cuomo was like please
come back
yeah yeah please and then uh you know
he's like i'll buy you a drink
so it's i i don't know if this is true
actually could you look this up that one
percent
the top one percent pays 50 percent of
the taxes in new york city
i have heard yeah i have heard so i've
heard it i don't know if it's true but
bill de blasio was like yeah they're
fair weather friends i should raise
their taxes more
oh my gosh and i'm like now you're going
to lose more money yeah
you're attacked so we talked about this
how trump brought all these rich people
in yeah in the early 80s started started
spending mad tax money which trump
basically re
redefined what new york was like they
all that money that he brought in in the
early 80s
changed the crime rate was dropping over
the over a decade after that
it's pretty incredible well once you
really look into the history of what new
york was
in the 70s versus the 80s it's a big
difference
yeah i did and i'm going to read this
short little blurb from the new york
post from a few years ago
it says new york city's one percent are
paying a much larger share of the city's
income tax than the wealthiest one
percent
nationally are coughing up to washington
interesting but you know what the
numbers are
they the big apples top 35 400 filers
those with incomes of 598 000 or more
accounted for 45.7 percent of the 7.2
billion dollars in income taxes that new
york city collected
wow 45 percent well they're all gone
yeah they're all leaving
because this is the thing man so the
reason i brought up that mall scenario
before okay new york city is basically
exploring the big mall
you're you're right wow yeah so so think
about it when someone goes to like soho
um what is what does soho stand for do
you know uh south of houston
south of houston there you go yeah so
this is an area they got a bunch of
boutique shops
the van store was over there i'm pretty
sure okay was it i think i think it was
south of houston
i don't remember maybe it was north of
it anyway here's the point no ho
noho yeah north houston you have all
these businesses
and so we would walk down and look in
the windows and but oh it's cool you
know let's go in here oh it's the vans
door i'll buy some skate gear you walk
out you walk down the street oh there's
best buy
so you're basically window shopping like
it's a big shopping district it's a good
point
yeah now that all these business now now
now that all these businesses were just
ripped to shreds index and just burnt to
the ground figuratively by the riots
and shut down by covid what are you
going to walk around for
so now here's what's happening i believe
it is fair to say
that bill de blasio is burning new york
city to the ground
yeah and it seems intentional and i'll
tell you why he really does
he's mocking the rich people as they
flee while cuomo is begging him to come
back and even cuomo isn't doing the best
job in the world
de blasio is setting up check points and
a 14-day quarantine and ten thousand
dollar fines
you know what that does it makes sure no
tourist will come to the city until
that's over that's a good point
and tourism accounted for billions in
revenue yep like daily
billions yeah so now you've got no
tourists
so there's no sales revenue there's no
money being brought into the city this
is the thing about tourism this is why
everybody loves it
you get some dude from i don't know um
give me a columbus ohio
sure decides to visit new york he brings
with him a bunch of money and he goes
and he buys little statues of the
america
you know the statue of liberty little
little models of it and some american
flags buys an mta pass
buys food you know ghost time square
theater
yeah hotel yeah everything that money
was generated in columbus
brought to new york and dispersed in new
york bolstering the new york economy
that's why tourism it's not i mean
people know how tourism works
bill de blasio said um how can we stop
this money from coming in checkpoints
and a two-week quarantine why is he
doing now we know for a fact you're here
and if you come out of your your
apartment house or hotel for within
two weeks ten thousand dollar fine maybe
he's hoping
he's gonna start you know capturing what
few
tourists are left in finding them ten
thousand dollars oh my goodness
or in all in all reality people aren't
walking around and shopping anymore
nope they're not going to be coming into
the city there's going to be zero
tourism
and and now he's mocking the rich people
as they flee
when you say he's mocking him like give
me an example because i don't i haven't
heard this yet
he called them fair weather friends oh
my goodness he called him fairweather
friends and he said he should raise
their taxes
cuomo said the opposite he says come on
i'll buy you a drink come back
there's no way they're going to come
back because they're they're finding a
new spot
realizing they're making so much more
money because they don't have to pay as
much taxes
in these other places and those other
places are probably like we love your
taxes that you're giving us
you're bolstering our community now it's
yes absolutely
but it's also just like the the
disrespect and abuse
yeah from the city yeah of course what
i'm saying are
that's why i'm saying is he trying to
make sure no one ever comes back
yeah well it's not look at what happened
with flint michigan with their water
how everyone though everyone had to pay
more and more for the water and then
they couldn't even afford water anymore
that's what i'm saying with this small
analogy
yeah so as warm as more and more people
leave new york city
then there's less of a reason for anyone
to be there it is a massive
mall essentially the incentive to be in
new york is because you're around other
people doing jobs because you can find a
job
and because there's content opportunity
a lot of people and your friends your
friends are gone
you can't make money you're locked in
your apartment there's no more tourism
there's nothing to sell the stores are
all destroyed by the riots
and then bill de blasio's laughing at
the people who are fleeing and have the
means to do so
leaving behind poor people who have no
money to spend can't get out of the city
while he laughs the whole way meanwhile
bill de blasio it's reported makes nine
thousand dollars a month in rental
income
as he mocks these people fleeing he's
fine he's totally fine
so i'll tell you what the rich people in
new york are going wow this bill de
blasio fellas sure is nuts
i'm leaving and they they hop on their
little private planes or whatever i mean
someone making 600k doesn't have a
private plane probably
maybe they rent a helicopter to fly him
out of the city then they go spend some
time upstate
they go spend some time in connecticut
in maine in boston or they go west coast
they go to montana they go down to
virginia whatever the point is they're
gone
they're leaving new york the poor people
can't do that the people in brooklyn and
central brooklyn
bed-stuy in these areas who live in
these tiny apartments they can't just up
and leave
so the whole city is being destroyed by
the failures of this mayor
that's democratic mayor and the
democratic governor and the poor people
are suffering the most
and and crime is skyrocketing because
he's defunding the police
taking you know the crime units out of
the out of these places that needed them
that are actually begging for them to
come back like please
bring the the police back people are
being shot and killed
non-stop it's been happening they're
facing a 30
billion dollar deficit over two years
they're they're demanding
federal intervention otherwise they're
gonna lay off 22 000 people and i don't
think trump's going to do it
he's going to be like i think he already
told him no the one time
now we're gonna see the government lay
off 22 000 people the police reassigned
600 cops soon they're going to start
firing people and it's going to go way
back to the way things used to be
violent crime rampant crime but maybe
even worse
i don't understand how new york could
function
if it collapsed to a certain degree
listen
if you have a water system as big as new
york city
i can't imagine how much it cost to
maintain that whole water system
ridiculous sums of money yeah you're
right uh buildings all that stuff
now what happens if everybody leaves and
there's no one to pay the bills for it
anymore
the people left see all of their water
bills go way up
they have to now all of a sudden no one
can afford to pay the water bill like
flint like detroit
and the city becomes on it becomes
basically uninhabitable
what's going to happen to new york are
people everyone
everyone in the city is going to leave
until there's only like a million people
left and
a metro that used to have 12 or 13. i
got to watch uh escape from new york
again
because yeah i mean that seems to be the
future
yes i mean i don't wish this upon new
york i love i grew up in new york
as i became an adult i moved there when
i was 19 and lived there until i was
i don't know 30 something i'm 34 when i
left
yeah bill de blasio has has burnt that
city to the ground
yes he has you i mean there's been bad
mayors you you know bloomberg was really
dumb
that guy was like taxing soda he's like
you know people are so stupid so let's
build mike bloomberg actually argued for
a poor tax
wow he said tax the poor because they're
not smart enough to know what's good for
him
she said those words i'm paraphrasing oh
my goodness
yeah he said the issue is poor people
will buy a bunch of soda and then get
unhealthy and fat
and we have to pay for it and then we
have to pay for it so how about we tax
them so they can't buy it
and then they'll have health care and
they'll be better off they're not even
thinking about the fact that they
they've created these food deserts where
they have no choice but to go to
mcdonald's because there's no other
places
everything else is a little bodega that
has barely anything
the bodegas have just like you know
noodles yeah but
they're not cooking stuff at a they're
going to a bodega to get a sandwich
and that's what they're living on you
know get a soda and a sandwich and it's
like that's not healthy either
that's that that was my life when i was
living in in williamsburg too
for vice wake up in the morning get
ready to go to work i go to bodega and
they give me a
man as much as i i love a nice bodega
sandwich
i gotta admit they're like low quality
low quality it's low quality food man
you know some american cheese on a
kaiser bun with some some meat
now they used boar's head boars that's
legit but those buns were not all that
good
processed meat in general is not good
for you i'll tell you boar's head
included
i mean i'm saying it's not like some
trash you know
it's like it's low quality stuff that's
the point yeah boar's head is not that
bad
but the point is i don't the face of
this country the shape of this country
is going to be so dramatically different
you know now you got bill i think it was
was it bill de blasio complaining about
census
yes oh yeah only 58 has been filled out
that means they're going to lose two
electoral votes
i saw that two electoral votes that's
good
the the democrats have got to be scared
so
obviously we from what we have learned
about what trump said
that he's got all these enemies that
they're he's gonna go
he's gonna go away for a little bit
you're not gonna see him for a little
while
i think it's because these people know
trump's gonna win
they're looking at the ameri the
american public and the american public
is just
going like this like we are going to
vote for trump because we see you
we everyone is aware like the great
awakening is what they keep sharing you
know and it's like
i see it too i'm a part of it myself and
now that we learned that the journalist
bubble
is worse now than it was in 2016. so for
those that didn't see this the other day
it was a university at illinois urbana
champaign i think
that's what's called and they said that
the the beltway bubble the dc politico
reporters
are more isolated than they were last
time and they were expecting to see the
inverse
so everybody wondered why did they get
everything wrong in the last election
and now it's because they were just
following each other and they were
completely out of touch with america
yeah so the new york times did this like
famous thing where they sent a guy
around the country to talk to middle
america and be like what did we not
understand
and now apparently it's worse than it
was before
it's worse so all these political
stories you're seeing where it's like
trump finally admits it he's losing
it's probably just bunk it totally is
bunk it's two
he's gonna win it's landslide two creepy
looking dudes in the bathtub together
going did you hear that trump is losing
i think trump is gonna lose two you
think he's going to lose he's definitely
going to lose
oh he's so losing that's all it is dude
i don't want that
come on it's uh who
who i'm not going to name okay i was
thinking of like which which i can think
of two
no no out of my head
please no that's what it is they're
going back and forth that's true
but we'll see man yep so there was a new
nbc news put out their new numbers and
it's like joe biden landslide that's
what they're saying
not no joke they're saying biden's
guaranteed like 333
electoral votes solid and there's 79
toss-ups he might win
and they're like joe biden might get 400
electoral votes
[Laughter]
they're delusional i really here's the
thing man it sounds like they're
suffering from the same thing blindness
dementia
i yes i have uh professional criticisms
of trump
a lot of the things i complain about in
the past trump has improved on
i i am i'm not a fan of you know his
demeanor as a president
but that's about it i think he's a funny
guy well because he was because he
wasn't a politician but here's the point
i hate joe biden that guy is nasty and
many people should
did racism is showing oh man oh
for no reason my goodness did you guys
see this today when he was talking on
that stupid
live streaming and he mentions black
people and then he met he's like
they were talking about cuba they were
talking about illegal immigration
and and how and he just started talking
about
the um i don't remember exactly what
what words he chose that just like the
hispanic
community for but here's the point and
out of left field for no reason
he had no need to say this he brought it
up he's like
unlike the black people that are out
there you know the hispanic people are
very diverse
and it's like what wait wait and and it
was like with with with
um what do you say with some notable
exceptions right i'm like
when i saw that when i saw that my
goodness joe why did you just say that
why why did you literally just inject a
comment about the black community having
nothing when this conversation has
nothing to do with them
right if you want to if you want to say
that the hispanic community in this
country is very diverse
i would say that's true absolutely
you've got done people from venezuela
it's all you had to say you got people
from you know florida you've got people
from cuba you've got people from mexico
you've got guatemala honduras
i had a friend growing up whose family
was from from honduras all they
all spoke spanish and they're all very
different in many different ways yeah
but for some reason
joe biden is like let me just you know
inject some comments about the black
community for no reason
it's not a mystery it's his filter
is is filtering away because of his
dementia
you know he was he's said many racist
things in his life or if you you dig
into joe biden you see racism
throughout his entire career and now
it's like
it's like the level the racism knob is
being turned up
and his filter's going away because of
dementia like that's why they hide him
exactly i actually used to see this with
my patients when i worked in the nursing
home and rehab centers
your filter goes away when you pass a
certain point yeah dementia makes it
you say whatever is crossing your body
if it makes sense
is it dementia or is it like you're old
and you just don't care anymore no
dimension
medical people today that were
commenting on my post about it they're
like this is
a telltale sign of dementia because it
you know they could they could have even
have had a change of heart and later on
in their life
and not be racist anymore but then as
dementia sets in
it reverts back to an older time that it
just kind of
yeah it's long i mean if he ever was
wasn't racist because i'm fairly certain
that never went away the crazy thing
about what he said it was
first and foremost why yeah it had
nothing to do with the conversation just
like let me just say something bad about
this group of people yeah and it's not
even
true he's like i'm just gonna go for a
hail
just a punch a haymaker right to the
face for no reason
have you have you noticed his filter
moments where biden will be talking
he'll be like listen here you know we
gotta you know i'm not gonna say that
because that would have been bad
yeah have you seen those moments
multiple times yeah he did it in this in
the same interview it's because his
filters busted yep
and he's struggling to keep it up so
he's like
i'm gonna he's like you know i want to
make a meme joke but i'm not gonna do
did you just pull a biden no no this one
because it's going to get me in trouble
on you
okay but biden may as well i'll i'll
i'll save the meme
but i'll stop short of it might as well
make biden may as well be singing a
chair
and then out of nowhere goes i'm going
to say it i'm going to
if you know the meme i don't know the
name i don't know you got it
i got to look at it show us afterwards
i'm going to say it cj
cj pearson on twitter he posted this
video talking about it you know he's a
he's a prominent
you know black american and he he was
just saying like i can't believe
all the racism people aren't getting
angry at
him like what is going on and then then
he makes a point he goes
if this is what we're seeing in public
what do you think he's saying about us
when no one's looking
it's like hillary's public and private
positions thing she mentioned yeah i'm
sure
back in back in the 2016 cycle she said
you got to have your public position in
your private position
oh goodness because she was against gay
marriage yeah
dude uh insane it's it's
joe biden the the people who are going
to vote for him
in my opinion the people who are reading
white fragility
they're white supremacists absolutely
with guilty consciences that's what it
is
it's not a joke it's not an exaggeration
technically correct
robin d'angelo is her name yep robin
d'angelo writes in the book that she is
a racist
at what point did the liberal the left
whatever start taking their cues from
people who are avowed racists
this is so funny to me because they love
the quote when someone shows you who
they are the first time
believe them yeah okay robin i believe
you
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live
monday through friday at 8pm if you want
to catch the full show
tune in to this channel subscribe hit
the like button or
check us out on itunes and spotify and
we will soon have this podcast up for
free
on all podcast platforms thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next episode
you